this is very important to me I have a
lot of young black men that follow me
there's no [__] way on Earth I'm
gonna let them believe that they have a
lesser chance than anybody else if they
just work their ass off there's no
[__] way I'm not sitting on their
dreams like that I'll be damned you call
me a racist if you want time but we have
to call me a racist all day I'm not I
don't care there's no way I'm letting
those young men believe that [__] 100
because I know plenty of black guys but
King rich is here right now is a [__]
winner all day long because he didn't
let that [__] happen 100 but we have to
work hard enough what about threat what
about all of our friends that are black
that are very very successful
looking at racism is for broke people
I just find the insulting it's not it's
not insulting you lead with it get a new
identity